look i've done every job under the sun
channing tatum is taking what he's
learned over the years to support his
girlfriend zoe kravitz in the latest
issue of variety where shannon is seen
on the cover barefoot wearing a nude
sweater and linen pants he opens up
about the professional advice he gave
zoey about her directorial debut in the
new thriller interestingly named [ __ ]
island a film he's also starring in
shannon told the magazine he advised zoe
not to direct and take on an acting role
in the film saying quote i was like
you'll need double the days she's a
perfectionist in the best possible way
is that a deal shake
this comes after the actor had his own
co-directing experience for the movie
dog in which he plays an army ranger who
has to bring a military working dog on a
road trip in time to attend her
handler's funeral yeah it's true it's
true shannon and zoe's relationship has
continued to blossom since they were
first romantically linked in august of
2021 she's so beautiful it's insane
she's the sweetest thing at the time a
source confirmed to et that quote zoe
and shannon are dating it started out as
a friendship and eventually turned to be
more a source later told et things are
quote easy and natural between them
i'm really blessed man in october they
celebrated their first halloween
together
taking it back to the 70s with their
1976 classic taxi driver costumes
you do know you're not dash right dash
is a character i made up that's like oh
my god
after a long hiatus the 41 year old is
set to make his return to the big screen
with multiple upcoming projects
including the lost city which also stars
sandra bullock and a third installment
of the magic mike franchise
channing needs that moment in november
et spoke with sandra at the premiere of
her new movie the unforgivable and the
oscar-winner joked about taking the
spotlight away from channing tatum in
the upcoming magic mike sequel he's
doing a lot of you know asking for me to
come on board
with my skills um in the stripping world
which are
they're world renowned um
i don't know if i want to do it and then
take the attention away channing needs
that moment
um
and if i step on stage you know what's
going to happen it's like all eyes are
going to be on this
it's all going to be on
on mama
yeah not really but
in my world that's what would happen
like all eyes would just shift off of
channing and onto me and they would stay